99-91 let us say look take a look at the
response of the Ukrainian side in the
Diaspora syndra UK and diaspora did not
possess a comparable in quality and
quantity publishing enterprise at the
patella school two are in the Institute
eat at ski and their political
strategist like years you get it and his
and his interpreter of political ideas
Yuri Chmerkovskiy there were this they
were there was a different system of
cooperation however and we could have to
keep in mind that was a great difference
in the status of foreign and you came
from Western perspective well the
existence of Poland as a country and
separate state or by with an MA day